[Music]
we were lucky to get out of those escape
rooms alive
i need to know that the criminals who
killed the four people in front of me
are held accountable
we're hiding in plain sight in the
middle of manhattan we need to stop them
i'm in i know this is a lot to ask but
thank you for coming with me
hey what the hell is going on
you guys have played the game before so
what is this like a tournament of
champions
[Applause]
look we all know how this works we
solved the puzzles or we died
i was advertising most people this ad
yourself is missing an e
so maybe we pull the corresponding
handles with a missing letter
yes
[Music]
this is way bigger than last time you
gotta try something right
yes there's a special reason each of us
survived i
can't feel physical pain just imagine
the kinds of puzzles they came up with
for me
take a picture it'll last longer get
some clues
this looks just like the lighthouse on
the postcard
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna
[Music]
not ever
need it we made it
i don't understand we're still in the
game
[Music]
you